I set it up you've got this song
triangle ABC and its scaly okay and then
you have a rectangle inscribed within it
and that rectangle can move so I think
it's called pol all right now what we
want to show is that the biggest of that
area of that rectangle can be the
biggest thing you get is half of the
full triangle okay so we're looking for
a stationary point where this area is
half of that okay so to make any start
on this you need to assign some variance
right the sides and variables also sites
and constants so I've picked out four
I've called the area of the whole
triangle okay let that area I'll call
the capital n now just as a arm just as
a convention and just to make things
easier for you to solve we try to make
try to make constants capital variables
lowercase and angles as Greek letters
okay so that's why you see you know
theatres and alpha Z games and that kind
of thing so that's just to help us I
know there's two days but when you're
doing your working we're not gonna be
talking about any actual coordinates
really we're just talking about links
that's my whole area I also need to know
the perpendicular height of this whole
triangle okay so I've got this yeah I'm
gonna call that perpendicular height H
now I could work at the base right but I
don't need to work out the base as
another variable because the base is
going to be a function of these two
right as you'll see shortly so we're not
going to introduce now sorry another
course that I really should make this
capital H yes okay so capital H constant
constant all right let's keep going now
I'll introduce the variable parts there
okay now the variable parts are the
dimensions of this rectangle okay
because they can move about when we can
change it it can be a really flat one or
really tall one that kind of thing so
I'm calling the width of the rectangle
PQRS I think I called an X X because
it's a horizontal thing right so weight
and the height of the same rectangle as
Y now the theme at these two variables
is I will actually be able to get rid of
one eventually okay but it takes some
time to get there I'm gonna get one in
terms of the other I'm just gonna leave
them there for now so if that makes that
makes that Y right that part there so
therefore this section up here for that
little small triangle up top will be the
total height - okay this part across the
bottom that's going to be next and if I
want to work out that this length BC
okay because I know the area of a
triangle right the area of a triangle is
on base times height on - right
well my area is actually called a right
my base is what I want to work out
calculation so when I rearrange this
write the base I'm off dog is aah hey
Mike on 2:00 a.m. a twinge okay
so I'm gonna call this whole the baby
down bottom - okay so now I'm set up now
this is um this is where the weird bit
comes in and I know some people will not
be very comfortable we've been doing
this but deal with it anyway it makes
things a lot easier to work with
is it what you've got down here this we
trapezium looking shape here okay
PQ sea beans trapezium right what I'm
gonna do is take that trapezium and I'm
gonna slice out the rectangle in the
middle okay you're like hmm you'll see
why in a second if I take that out which
I can totally do because the rectangle
right the sides are equal
okay what I'm gonna get is this new
shape right this is also going to be in
a point Q it's gonna move over because
it sort of collapses this is going to be
C over here and in the middle you've got
point s it's also point mark they're the
same okay so I'm gonna call this
triangle graceful another good as usual
grant I'm gonna call her this triangle
PVC and I can show you that this
triangle and the one tall right can you
see they're going to be similar right
you've got because of this rectangle
here you've got parallel lines right so
you've got a hold on a bunch of cars
many angles which I'm going to show this
so that's how we do this
triangle PBC and triangle of one on the
top a thank you okay just similarity all
I need is two angles right so I'll just
use corresponding angles to go this pair
and okay you see that that's not too
hard right so let me just what what
actually right now I'm going to say
angle a PQ is equal to angle P BC
because corresponding angles on those
parallel lines are equal okay I mean
that's just a few times yeah
abbreviations I mean we kind of do use
abbreviations where there's no ambiguity
all right well when there's like work at
for instance if you saw this okay we
allow that for congruence but we don't
allow for similarity because like side
side side but what about them all right
the fact that they are in proportion so
when you abbreviate that you lose some
meaning when you abbreviate this you
don't lose me thank you
okay weird context right no I'm not
doing calculus okay so therefore I've
got those two angles equal I can say
similarly because exactly the same
reason angle a QP they're the opposite
ones equal to anymore piece of it okay
so similar
okay so far so good
where am I going here okay when I've got
these two similar triangles right I can
relate a whole bunch of these variables
and constants together okay
namely this triangle here that I just
introduced right its height is y right
because I got it from young its base is
the whole base of the whole triangle -
the rectangle parts are cut out right so
this base here from here to here is
that's the whole base and that's the
rectangle clock right it's all
subtractive - H - okay then what this is
going to let me do is when I do similar
triangles in car 20 science I'm gonna
get some ratios that allow me to well I
could these variables okay so here's
what I've got
now just for the sake of time I'm just
going to cut that but you guys know what
it is cutting lengths in similar
triangles are in the same ratio or in
proportion okay here's my reason so what
am I what's my goal here I'm needing to
use these ratios to find the
relationship between x and y so I don't
have X&Y anymore do you remember the
whole idea in maxima questions is
eliminate everything down to as few
variables you can ideally one because
that you can differentiate finds
stationary points and so on okay so I'm
actually going to up you're going to
cross multiply this simplify out after a
life deliberating here's where you end
up I get x equals this okay